اعاده التدوير هي التقاء البيئه مع
الاقتصاد من المتوقع ان يحقق هذا السوق ما
يصل الى 4.5 تريليون دولار امريكي بحلول
عام 2030 قدرت دراسه ان دول مجلس التعاون
الخليجي وحدها يمكن ان توفر ما يصل الى
100.38 مليار دولار بحلول لعام 2030
بتطبيق النهج الدائري على اقتصادها
وبالنسبه للقطاعات لتكون البدايه بالاسهل
طبقا لاحصائيه فانا انتاج طن واحد من
مخلفات ورقيه سيوفر طاقه باربعه الاف ومئه
كيلو وات في الساعه كان 45% من استهلاك
الغابات في العالم يذهبوا لي انتاج الورق
وبالنسبه لاعاده التدوير المخلفات معدله
يعتبر الصلب من المخلفات التي يمكن اعاده
تدويرها بالنسبه
لا نهائيه من المرات اما تكاليف اعاده
تدوير الالمنيوم فانها تمثل 20% فقط من
تكاليف تصنيعه اما المواد البلاستيكيه
تقدر قيمه مخلفاتها الاقتصاديه باكثر من
120 مليار دولار امريكي سنويا ومن المتوقع
ان يصل حجم سوق اعاده تدويرها الى 900
مليار دولار في عام 2005